quem aqui chegou
quem aqui chega traz sempre um sonho de
algum lugar
todos são iguais corações a se entregar
com coragem disse a ventura vida sonho
esperança paz paz e esperança
quem a que chegou
quem aqui chega
a hola gente tudo bem com vocês
é com muito orgulho que pedrina mulher
negra baiana e nordestina e quilombola
veio lá do sul da bahia de um livro o
quilombo chamado jatimane região da
costa do dendê conhecida como baixo sul
também tem 51 comunidades quilombolas
certificadas pela palmares e dentro
deste número está essa comunidade a qual
nasci moro e pretendo levar para o mundo
e é nessa vontade de trazer o mundo pra
dentro da comunidade que eu vou começar
contando pra você um pouco dessa
trajetória
aos 11 anos provocada na escola com a
temática muito importante meio ambiente
eu tinha lá meus 11 anos de idade quando
a professora me pediu para escrever um
texto sobre a questão ambiental e muito
me entristecia porque primeiro horário
que lomba na fati zta 0 o acesso à
educação 0 e eu dizia como eu vou falar
disso né
dentro de uma realidade difícil só que
por outro lado eu vocês olham mas a
imagem aqui ver que lindo é uma das
áreas mais protegida de mata atlântica
isso porque aquele povo que mora lá
sempre preservou e cuidou
então meu texto foi trabalhado numa
realidade de que forma pedrina pode
fazer a diferença eu comecei a me
colocar a serviço e sente se parte
daquele processo e aí é quando tudo
começa e eu estou muito emocionada nesse
momento porque está aqui no ted x 2017 é
consolida o sonho de levar um com o
mundo para a comunidade por meio do
protagonismo que poderia ser pode ser eu
poderia ser você poderia ser você cada
um pode levar o seu a sua localidade
para onde quiser basta ter vontade e
força de vontade
basta se sente se parte
e aí é que começa e tendo sempre como
base a família né a família como aquele
motivador
naquela época as pessoas eram bem
francesa no quilombo é resistente né
não acreditava muito nas coisas e uma
das pessoas que marcou também nesse
processo a minha vida foi meu pai que
infelizmente deu já levou mas que me
ensinou uma coisa sorrir torre torre e
esta imagem aqui eu tinha 16 anos quando
eu comecei minha trajetória lá foi
provocada pelo meio ambiente mas foi
provocada na câmara de vereadores
discutir com as o poder público de que
forma a gente podia revolucionar o mundo
porque a gente sabe que cada um de nós
somos responsável mas aí existe o poder
público às iniciativas privadas e existe
o papel de cidadão então eu comecei a me
assumir enquanto o jovem enquanto
moradora daquele que logo que eu podia
fazer a diferença ea partir daí eu fui
mobilizando outros atores outras
instituições que me estimularam a
acreditar que eu poderia chegar além
através do meu sonho e aí eu comecei um
trabalho de base junto com o jovem da
comunidade e jovens que isso muito sonho
com muita perspectiva mas sabe que
faltava oportunidade que assim como
pedrina que pensava em sair de sua
comunidade para buscar oportunidade fora
milhares de outras pessoas tinham essa
vontade mas só esse trabalho lá inicial
que fez com que as pessoas se assumissem
como moradora do quilombo se assume se
como cidadão se assume se como partícipe
dessa sociedade então trazer essa
reflexão do empoderamento da afirmação
de uma identidade que precisa ser
trabalhada desde o início para que a
gente possa assim abraçar o sonho
coletivo porque eu sempre acreditei que
eu posso
você pode 'nós podemos nós podemos
revolucionar o mundo e esse sempre foi o
meu lema então eu abracei minha
comunidade com um propósito de vida
então hoje aos 27 anos eu tive tantas
coisas na vida e me ajudou a não me
preocupar
amigo apenas me preocupar com o coletivo
me preocupar com a população que sonha e
acredita que tem força de vontade de que
acredita que quando você se assume assim
como negra como branco como pardo
você pode fazer a diferença e esse foi
um dos pontos mais importantes é forte
na minha vida eu me assumir como mulher
negra e saber que eu poderia fazer a
diferença na minha localidade
então eu viajei para vários lugares
participei de inúmeros eventos é como eu
disse que a família foi importante foi
porque minha mãe tá aqui meu pai não
está mas meu pai dizia sempre falei que
acreditava em mim que eu podia ir além e
eu tenho certeza que ele de lá onde está
ele está percebendo levando jatimane
para o mundo levando jatimane protege x
então pra mim é motivo de muito orgulho
e um dos pontos importantes é focar nas
pessoas
esse foi o trabalho que ajudou a
acreditar que era possível transformar
aquela realidade focando nas habilidades
nas competências no modo de viver no
sonho de cada um e olha que essa platéia
veja olhares que tem vontade que tem
sonho e tem perspectiva e quando a gente
abraça isso pra gente como
responsabilidade a gente se auto
responsabilizar por algo que nos
incomoda faz a diferença porque talvez
se quando lá eu fui provocado a falar
sobre meio ambiente e cruzasse meu braço
escrevesse um simples texto e postar se
lá não ia fazer a diferença mais uma das
ações foi o primeiro mutirão de limpeza
do rio
e essa virou atração ano ao todo ano a
gente faz essa atividade porque não
depende do outro não depende de mim
e aí sim eu faço você deve seguir o
exemplo para outras pessoas
então todo esse trabalho de protagonismo
ele nasce da vontade de querer fazer
nasce do sonho nascido de você abraçar o
propósito e focar nas pessoas certas e
um dos trabalhos que pra mim marcou
minha vida nessa caminhada toda de 27
anos de idade
essa imagem que vocês vão ver a foi
pedrina sozinha
o que não for aquelas pessoas que eu
falei lá que nós focamos aquelas pessoas
que muitas vezes achava que não poderia
fazer nada e que fez e que largou dias e
noites entregando uma causa nobre e
superior
então tudo isso me motivava a acreditar
que era possível transformar o que era
possível fazer a diferença e se aqui
parece brincadeira mas o tema do ted há
sentido em um jardim sensorial no
quilombo do jat manny mobilizou a
comunidade no processo de identidade do
processo de empoderamento e no processo
de desenvolvimento local que é possível
continuar a comunidade fazendo a
diferença
basta você dá o toque pra ele dizer que
você vale a pena que você vale a pena
yuri e quando as pessoas se sentem
acolhidas elas colocam todo o seu
potencial a serviço e eu agradeço a deus
pela oportunidade de interagir com
tantas pessoas boas e eu gostaria de
citar o nome dela que está aqui na
platéia viana leite foi uma das minhas
líderes maravilhosas que me estimulou a
acreditar que era possível transformar
esse já diz é setorial simboliza que é
possível transformar a realidade onde
moramos por meio de uma ação efetiva
junto a pessoas junto ao olhar profundo
ao olhar se para dentro
ao se sentir se parte se a gente não se
colocar parte do processo a gente vai
estar sempre assim apontando que você
tem que fazer e os 4 apontando pra mim
dizendo a você pode fazer mais
todo mundo concorda comigo então sem
protagonista não está no palco é fazer
acontecer
ser protagonista é pensar mas você olhar
para o lado e saber que você também pode
fazer a diferença isabella
então é um motivo de muito orgulho pra
mim está aqui mostrando esse trabalho
que está fazendo a diferença no quilombo
da ajat mãe no interior da bahia e vocês
estão convidados para ir conhecer e
dizer
finalizando uma música porque o meu
sonho é que meu filho
ele tem acesso a uma vida digna e pra
ele eu preciso ser exemplo e fé na vida
fé no homem fé no que virá nós podemos
tudo nós poderemos mas vamos lá fazer o
que será
seja um protagonista da sua própria
história porque eu já faço um abraço pra
todos e muito obrigada
[Aplausos]